la télé avec des câbles c'est terminé
enfin presque Alger vient d'inventer un
boîtier qui permet de se connecter
directement sans fil à la télé alors on
connaissait déjà les boîtiers déportés
on le voit notamment avec Samsung vous
avez votre boîtier one Connect qui vient
se connecter juste avec un câble entre
le boîtier et le téléviseur là par
contre c'est une techno qui est
complètement nouvelle que nous propose
LG ici vous avez votre moniteur vous
avez un boîtier qui est à distance et
qui communique sans fil tout le signal
est envoyé sans fil sur le boîtier vous
pouvez connecter il y a trois prises
HDMI il y a deux prises USB vous avez
également une prise satellite antenne si
vous le souhaitez vous branchez le
boîtier sur le secteur vous branchez la
télé sur le secteur pas plus de câble LG
ne veut pas communiquer sur la
technologie j'imagine que c'est une
connexion qui se fait en wifi peut-être
sur une bande de fréquence propriétaire
allez savoir mais ce que je trouve super
intéressant c'est de se dire on enlève
les câbles à la maison ça donne des
intérieurs beaucoup plus jolis et une
fois de plus on va comment la
technologie vient améliorer nos maisons
nos intérieurs je trouve ça juste
passionnant bravo LG dites-moi vous ce
que vous en pensez et est-ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser d'avoir une
télé sans aucun câble marquer le moi
dans les commentaires